c'est quoi le paradis un endroit
paisible dans le ciel
toi tu vas aller au paradis
pourquoi
[Musique]
l'intelligence artificielle qui avait
été conçu pour nous protéger à lancer
une logique nucléaire sur Los Angeles
nous ne cesserons de la traquer
c'est notre existence même qui est en
jeu
je sais pas ce qu'il y a dedans mais ils
avaient pas envie qu'on est en train ou
que quelque chose en sorte
[Musique]
toi et moi on est pareil on ne peut pas
aller au paradis
parce que toi tu es pas gentil
[Musique]
et moi je ne suis pas une personne
oui c'est une gamine
la victoire est abordée demain
exécuter là on nous disparaîtront
[Applaudissements]
c'est moi qui veulent